So going back to our mani-core challenges. Now
we have seen that the issue of power
budget splitting among cores is solved by using
a turbo frequency when using only one core, so
that a single-threaded program doesn't suffer just because
it's running in a multi-core system. Pretty much then
one core gets to use all the power
of the chip, with some limitations because of cooling.
And the final issue that we will look at
is the confusion that all of this brings to the
operating system. Keep in mind that it has to deal
with multi-threading, where each core can really execute several threads
in hardware. Then you have cores that can share
caches. Then if you have a larger system, you can
have multiple chips, each with its own large caches, and
you can have all of these at the same time.